皆さんに
報告しなければいけないことがありますあ動画のタイトルみたいな果実らは僕昨日から
[音楽]
学校に通ってます凄い問題僕の言ってる学校とは何の学校でしょうか
きつりゃー実は僕ですに昨日からあの
ドローンの
学校に通っておりますドローンスクールっていうんですけどやっぱみんなドローンで
分かりますあの
クっていうんでなんか最近祭とかでなんか墜落ドローンちょいにあるんですけどもう
使い方わからないなら一応使えるし
外で使ってもいいらしいんですけど
[音楽]
こっち子はいいですよ通訳とかしたらほんと怖いしていい何か変なとこで飛ばしてなく
犯罪になって捕まったりしても普通に嫌なんで大炎上したらもっとこう合法的に何か
動画の撮影とかにあゆ空撮っていうか空からの絵が撮りたいなんて思った時に死角は
無いんじゃねと思ってちょっとドローンを飛ばす資格をただいま取りに行って
おりますいやもう行かなきゃいけないんだけどやまずドローほんとすごいっすよまじで
感動します四角結構
なんかちゃんと成立なんで3日から4日間ぐらいかかる的なことを聞いてるんでもう
ちょっと多分通わなきゃいけないんですけどちょっと早くみなさんに俺のドローン操作
技術を見せるレベルっと思っています
じゃあ行きますか
ん
me
ええええええ
ふふ
ん
雪の空も雲ん
ています
彼は時開店して行ったら4
あっん
ブーブーウェアー
hey ん
こっちが乗ったん
ん
ana
tee
[音楽]
me
6 e
上に上がると
ておりません
練習するしかないなぁ
持って
あった
た
とって
オープン
tip
[音楽]
me
teame
うううう
me
me あった